people do in the democratic party
are there people in the republican party
who think we're sucking the blood out of
kids
they can't even stand by their own words
because they can see how deeply
unpopular they are joe biden
uh there are a number of clips of him
going around that are pretty
embarrassing i'm not even going to play
one of them
on the show though it's gone viral the
clip
the clip is joe biden screaming
something that seems as though he's
referring to his own anatomy and it's
just really it's one of these bizarre
outbursts
that biden has made but there are a
number of them out there
including he was asked a question are
democrats
are there democrats who want to defund
the police joe biden has a puzzling
answer
we are not defunding the police are
there
in the democratic party are there people
in the republican party you think we're
sucking the blood out of kids
i i'm not sure are there people in the
democratic party who want to
depend are there p are you defunding the
police he says are the people in the
republican party you think we're sucking
the blood out of kids which just as a
as a practical matter just as a very
narrow matter
the democrats are by supporting abortion
but the broader point is even more
preposterous
joe biden says we're not defunding the
police
what oh the republicans next they're
going to say we're sucking the blood out
of kids
which we are through abortion which
we're vigorously defending which i'm
actually trying to get taxpayers to fund
right now through the repeal of the hyde
amendment
okay neither here nor there
republicans when they say that democrats
want to defund the police
they're not making some outlandish claim
they're not they're not coming up with
some conspiracy theory as joe biden is
implying
they're just quoting the democrats own
words very very prominent
democratic politicians have said defund
the police
have called to defund the police have
put forward legislation to have
have successfully defunded the police
and very prominent democratic
politicians have said
abolish the police doesn't mean just
move some funding around or change the
training it means abolish the police it
means get rid of them
but joe biden makes them oh what's next
what are you what are you people going
to say next you say we're sucking the
blood out of kids
they can't even stand by their own words
because they can see how deeply
unpopular they are
because they can see that people are
waking up to what
this ruling class has done to them
we sucking the blood out of kids i mean
we are but
hey hold up there you idiots
i know you're you're idiots according to
the liberal establishment you're
obviously much more intelligent than
they are
it goes without saying but you know what
would make you an idiot
if you didn't subscribe and like and
ring the bell uh there's a whole episode
here you can go check that out called
the idiot percentage you get it at the
michael knowles show on apple podcast
spotify google play all of these other
things
and uh i hope to see you next time
especially if you've read my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
we can bask in our own deplorable
irredeemable bitter
clinging bible thumping idiocy together
see you next time
[Music]
you